des monstres ailés qui ne vole plus et
des aérogares désert avec la fermeture
des frontières et les mesures de
confinement qui gagnent davantage de
pays chaque jour le transport aérien
mondial vit l'une des plus graves crises
de son histoire
faute de passagers les compagnies
aériennes annonce les unes après les
autres la réduction ou la suspension de
leur activité moins 90% pour air france
qui suspend aussi les vols de ses deux
filiales up et transavia des chiffres
similaires sont annoncés par la
britannique virgin atlantic
l'autrichienne austrian airlines ou
encore l'irlandaise ryanair qui suspend
la quasi totalité de ses vols à compter
du 24 mars
elles sont des dizaines à être déjà
concernés par les réductions d'activité
et la liste s'allonge
conséquence les titres boursiers de ces
compagnies chute inexorablement à
l'image d'air france dont l'action a
perdu plus de la moitié de sa valeur en
un mois ou de l'allemande lufthansa
avait plus de 40% de baisse sur les
marchés d avion qui ne vole plus et des
capitalisations qui fondent comme neige
au soleil
les compagnies aériennes se crashe avec
en prime le risque de se faire racheter
pour une bouchée de pain résultat les
états se tiennent prêts à voler au
secours de leur compagnie et le mot
nationalisation revient sur toutes les
lèvres
l'italie premier pays européen touché
par le virus a d'ores et déjà prévenu
qu'elle reviendrait propriétaire
d'alitalia première compagnie nationale
déjà moribonde annonce similaire de
l'autre côté des alpes où l'on envisage
déjà de nationaliser la première
compagnie de l'hexagone ainsi que
d'autres entreprises menacées
s'il fallait aller jusque là dans un cas
d'extrême difficulté d'une entreprise
alors nous le ferions pour faire en
sorte que des entreprises est
essentielle au tissu économique français
ne disparaissent pas mais qu'il s'agisse
de simples renflouement ou de retour des
compagnies dans le giron des états ces
derniers devront tout de même mettre la
main à la poche
la grande question est de savoir combien
le manque à gagner ne cesse d'augmenter
au fil des semaines et des mesures
destinées à lutter contre le coc vide 19
de 30 milliards de dollars le 20 février
les pertes du secteur sont passés à 113
milliards le 5 mars
désormais ce sont 150 à 200 milliards de
dollars que les états devraient
débourser pour sauver leur compagnie
selon l'iata l'association
internationale du transport aérien
soit près d'un quart de point du pib
mondial et nul besoin d'attendre la fin
de l'épidémie pour voir les premières
banqueroute
la compagnie britannique flybe a déjà
déposé le bilan il ya une dizaine de
jours et ce n'est que le début
selon le cabinet australien capa
spécialisé dans l'aéronautique la
plupart des compagnies aériennes seront
en faillite d'ici à la fin du mois de
mai